thanks to state farm for sponsoring a
portion of today's video
this was the first cg animated character
in film history and it paved the way for
the entire vfx industry with a few
notable inventions we're gonna try to
basically recreate this we'll make a
cool character here and then we'll shoot
a short film as an homage to the
original
this portion of the video is sponsored
by state farm well the guys are in the
studio about to kick off this cgi
challenge i need to take a moment and
tell you about today's sponsor state
farm now state farm is a new sponsor to
the channel huge welcome to them and uh
please be nice because uh well they're
making this show possible so let me tell
you all about what they have to offer
now state farm understands better than
many other companies out there that
everyone has budgets and you don't have
to give up what you love just to get
great insurance and stay within your
budget this is the fundamental principle
of what they have to offer so here's
what they do they offer options that
allow you to get surprisingly great
rates on both your home and auto
insurance so that you don't have to give
up the things that you love now how do
they do this well it's very simple they
allow you to personalize aspects of your
policy which allow you to get more of
what you need and less of what you don't
and therefore stick within your budget
and get great insurance and not have to
make financial sacrifices in other areas
of your budget they understand look hey
nobody likes trade-offs but sometimes
you feel like there's no other choice
but guess what we have a solution for
you to help solve that so again if you
guys are looking for great insurance
look no further than state farm and huge
thanks to them for sponsoring today's
episode and making it possible here's my
best jake from state farm impression
okay are you ready here we go
for surprisingly great rates that fit
any budget like a good neighbor state
farm is there call or go to
statefarm.com to get a quote today
so that's it there you have it once
again thanks to state farm for
sponsoring this portion of the video
let's get into this challenge
we tend to mark the history of cgi over
the last several decades by the
groundbreaking characters that the
technology makes possible you know
you've got like the iconic ones you know
gollum i mean obviously we got the
jurassic park dinosaurs like you know
the abyss we got terminator 2 but if we
go back even further there are even
earlier renditions of digital characters
now the very first digital character
ever made was for the movie
future world in future world they
actually like built this like 3d model
of peter fonda's face in a super
rudimentary there was no way to like
composite that into live-action footage
so they're literally pointing a camera
at the computer screen like someone's
pirating transformers four so fast
forwarding a few more years there's a
couple other movies obviously there's
tron we did a whole video about that but
none of those were real characters
until young sherlock holmes
i love how it just like animates in just
like
all of this feels so much more advanced
than
the year yeah no kidding i mean in many
respects it holds up you know what i
mean yeah totally this was the first
fully photorealistic cg animated
character in film history it is and it's
crazy because you know when you're doing
when you're the first of anything you
are in open territory and you have to
navigate problems that have never been
navigated john lasseter was the one who
headed this up with the lucasfilm
computer graphic division which was
under ilm at the time and under his
leadership they executed this to
perfection and just a year later in 1986
were purchased by steve jobs and became
pixar
[Music]
you're talking about ilm in conjunction
with pixar forging the way for computer
animated cg characters in film i mean i
honestly coming into this had no idea of
the significance of this shot
i think there are nine visual effects
shots in this entire sequence and they
were revolutionary it took them nine
months
nine months for 30 seconds of on-screen
action that is wild and it paved the way
for the entire vfx industry with a few
notable like
inventions that they made beyond just
having a cgi character
so back in the day when they wanted to
animate something you had all of these
sort of like polygons and vertices on
the corners of each of those polygons
that they had to manually move like one
by one
right it completely circumnavigates any
sort of like artistic vision so they
invented this new way of animation
which we know today as just a character
rig the idea of a hierarchical character
rig i mean the way they described it was
like the branches of a tree you know you
got the body as like the trunk you can
move the whole trunk and all the
branches move with it and then the
branches start breaking off you can move
the arm and then you can move the rest
of the arm and the fingers one by one
you can animate the fingers
independently but it'll always be
tracked to where my arm is which will
always be tracked where the rest of my
arm and my body is and that gives you a
lot of power when you're animating
because i want to move the hips here the
whole body moves now i just move the
upper leg now just adjust adjust adjust
instead of having to go uh vertex by
vertex which sounds like
there are like 82 different unique
pieces forming the entirety of the
stained glass man and if they had to
like animate the position or rotation of
each of those pieces it would have taken
like 10 times longer
[Music]
this shot is the first cg rap focus shot
in cinema history john lasseter and his
team found a way to render out depth of
field specifically for this shot for
this shot with like the focus distance
actually changing going from the hands
to his face that would be a really hard
shot to do optically because you got the
matted lines being blurred at different
amounts at different points yeah but
they did something very new at the time
which was actually rendering out the
background plate digitally with the
actual render itself so this is like
essentially a fully cg shot but it's not
the background is technically a real
plate another crazy innovation here is
that this shot has camera match moving
camera tracking they literally invented
camera tracking it was like not a thing
but they had this camera moving through
3d space it's not just static it's not
just like pivoting around it's literally
translating through 3d space and they
had to straight up
recreate that camera motion in post but
there were no tools there was no after
effects camera tracker there was no
synth eyes but john lasseter was there
in the church measuring every square
inch of the cathedral so they could
remodel it just to track that one shot
yeah like you press a button now and it
like figures out where the camera is in
real space
heck our phones do it in real time
i didn't know this but in 1985 they
actually had motion blur capabilities
and this is one thing that dennis mirren
the visual effects supervisor was very
very adamant about because again these
were the days of stop motion you know
and the big hole that would stop motion
is the lack of motion blur it makes it
look like it's not a part of the image
so having an accurate motion blur is
very important when creating realism and
the idea behind this approach was to
create the first photo realistic
animated cg model so that motion blur
played a huge factor in this but of
course it came at a massive
computational cost and for you artists
out there you already know it's still a
pain in the butt to have motion blur and
depth of field so imagine in 1985 trying
to run that stuff for all these shots it
must have been a nightmare dude i saw
that for the abyss which was like what
1988 or so the entire computer graphics
department at lucasfilm
had 900 megabytes of storage
not even a gig
and that was the entire department
and like our server space here is now
like what 200 terabytes yeah another
thing that they did here which i find
actually really fascinating is the idea
of like selectively adding highlights to
the armor and so what they did which
seems very very logical john lasseter
took measurements and took note of
exactly where every single light source
was the color temperature of that light
source and the intensity and they
replicated that in 3d space for the
rendering of this thing and they took a
look at it was like it's not working
yeah this isn't good didn't feel right
didn't feel right exactly and so they
ended up going through and adding a
whole bunch of specific lights so that
they could get the correct glints it's
not exactly how it should have been in
the actual footage but it looks better
it looks more right and that's a
challenge that you faced with cg
characters right is the the dp on set
would light for the character if the
character was there and that might
change depending on what the character
looks like they might completely relight
the scene if the character was actually
there so when you get into the post side
doing it literally is a great starting
point but it's not always the best
solution for a good looking finish it's
still just nuts to me that they were
literally doing all this almost 40 years
ago is that four it is 40 years ago well
not quite it was like i mean no it's
close 84. it was like 38 years ago dude
and i think this marks like a really
interesting sort of like pivot point in
the film industry because they are able
to take all these super complicated
mathematical equations and algorithms
and all this stuff that they had to use
for like say tron remember tron's cgi
was all made with like freaking
spreadsheets
but for this they finally figured out a
way to optimize the use and execution of
these things so that an artist without
any sort of mathematical background can
use it easily yeah it's nuts yeah it's
almost like this is the first time we're
seeing the artist's mind prioritized in
the execution of visual effects yeah
it's just really fascinating to see all
the challenges they face and how those
challenges are still relevant today we
have far better tools far shorter
turnaround times because the ability
just to make this stuff and turn around
is so much faster but a lot of those
same sort of problems will exist today
so we're going to try to basically
recreate this we'll make a cool
character here and then we'll shoot a
short film as an homage to the original
let's see if we can use our modern tools
to see if we can actually do this
quicker and also make it more
photorealistic okay okay plan of attack
yes
we need a stained glass man first i
would suggest one of us dress up in like
some armor we take a photo and then we
just have griffin artistically interpret
that as a stained glass thing
i like that hey griffin
yo griffin
hey buddy hey what's up dude so what
we're gonna do is we're gonna put jordan
in some armor and i'm gonna take a photo
of him and i'd love if you could just
like trace over it and turn him into
like a stained glass character just just
press the stained glass filter
actually i do have one of those wait for
real i don't know
how good it's gonna be but i'll i'll do
a version with that for sure
dude we're in the costume room you
remember this from when jake disappeared
on us because he was being batman i
recognize this
i'm going to be called laurie
[Laughter]
so we don't really have any sort of like
armor let's see if we can make some sort
of like costume that is armor-esque dude
already baseball pads those are going on
yeah fantastic yeah these are your leg
armor oh dude this is from our mad max
film something like that you know like
have that on your shoulders i like that
i take that
just be iron man just be iron man dude
stained glass iron man
is that is that a saddle a saddle we
gotta get you a helmet oh i know what
we're doing oh yeah so this is from like
the main orc captain from our shadow of
mordor short film this thing is made out
of pure resin so it weighs like 10
pounds but it looks super sweet wait do
you have a big head i'd like to think so
i have awoken
come on baby if i show up in a war like
this
whoa
which way am i going wait should we look
at the fictional reference like no we're
not getting nervous dude he's getting
nervous at the creative freedom here
look let the creativity flow
i'm ready for war
but i've never seen what happened
what went wrong
here try the sword
no no i'm not feeling i'm not feeling
that sword this sword's a little bit
lighter
kind of fits my vibe oh my gosh
what is this made out of metal
appropriate i mean i think this could be
a good like stained glass man type sword
good luck holding it
in t-pose as long as it's okay that i'm
openly weeping in the post
i feel perfectly safe in my gear
andrill the sword of aragorn son of
aerothorn
[Music]
thank you my lord
do you want like a shard blade we got
like this thing here
oh that's dope that's so big look at the
size of this sword well the original
stained glass man was seven and a half
feet tall so it only feels right that's
a pretty legit sword too yeah i like
this i like this sword let's go with
this one this is like an actual shard
blade oh is it really i mean it's not
actually but it's like the size of a
shard blade yeah that's very sweet yeah
all right i'm gonna go grab griffin to
see if you can take these photos real
quick
[Music]
i love it
we got our knight in shining armor he
looks great i just need you to take some
photos of him real quick hey jordan come
on out
oh dude
you just broke it
the armor just broke
[Music]
down what just happened
this is a tale that will be uh
immortalizing stained glass for all time
i'm excited okay all right good so
yesterday uh we took
this photo of our that's what i look
i like have not seen it to this point i
was able
to make
that's awesome
that is awesome
wow dude
that's great
oh my gosh
i see a little bit of my soul in there
this is hilarious
thank you dude this is so killer okay so
i guess the next bit here is to
basically take this and turn that into a
3d model which essentially just means
taking it and getting an outline of it
and extruding that in 3d space so we'll
probably want to like break out your
your hand into a few different pieces
your arm into a few different pieces
because they're all just going to be
basically flat 2d cutouts moving in 3d
space separately i'll start trying to do
that while you really figure out the new
deep motion thing
dude
it worked
are you kidding
this is literally going to work freaking
work dude yeah this is not what i
expected look at this oh my gosh off
just a video
so i did this animation test with this
program called deep motion that
basically just takes a video of your
motion and then generates 3d animation
from it and you can put in like any
video too like you can pull like
dance moves from step up or something
into this and it'll like get the
animation of those dance moves that's
amazing dude yeah this is great this is
great so in theory we should be able to
actually upload our own sort of rigged
model to this and we'll just apply that
animation data to it automatically which
would be very ideal
okay i believe we have all of the
building blocks necessary now to proceed
let's go ahead and shoot this short film
i really want to film this on my iphone
because there's this app i've been using
called by play camera and it tracks the
footage in real time and it also allows
me to actually use a 3d character as a
stand-in for me to compose the shop
properly and at the end of it all it'll
even spit out a cinema 4d file with
everything ready to go then after that
we'll shoot your mocap and submit that
to deepmotion to get a ready to go
animation
[Music]
all right so i've finished the edit here
i've assembled everything that we shot
is jordan acting across from jordan here
man jordan's dancing if you want to
actually see more about jordan's dancing
we did an entire crew cuts episode on
quarterdigital.com check it out we deep
dive into what it means to dance in
front of people like no one's watching i
might need to see the worm done in
person right here right now if you're up
to it
so i edited this whole thing
traditionally like i normally would but
normally the next step of the process i
would kick this out to after effects and
then camera track it lay out the ground
plane the walls and all of this stuff to
kind of build out the geometry but no
this time around that's already been
done for me
while i recorded the footage the phone
was able to essentially scan the
environment here and as you can see
here's a cg camera moving through the
environment here the exact same way i
was in real life
and on top of that is projecting the
footage
on to this geometry here everything is
already set up at real world scale i
should be able to just drop in the
animation which i made to be seven feet
tall and it'll just
fit
automating all of those processes
allowed me to kind of spend a lot of my
creative energy on dialing in the
materials i was able to build out the
actual textures and the look of stained
glass right you know glass it's
see-through but one of the things dennis
mirren said was that everything seemed
very flat and they ended up adding
something like six or seven layers of
sort of like scratches and little
bubbles and whatnot just to add extra
detail to the actual textures and i've
done that here too you can see all the
scratches i've added to the glass and
the glass is also slightly transparent
so you can see through it but one of the
things i discovered when doing this was
that it wasn't looking how i needed it
to look until i
actually added that color channel into
the emission channel so technically the
glass is emitting
a little bit of light just a little bit
just enough to kind of like boost
the color values just a little bit i
don't know if adding an emissive channel
like that to this is technically
realistic but you know what it looks
better this way and so you know what i
don't feel so bad i think because it
looks good
it works that's what i learned from
dennis mir
so there's still a lot of work left to
do here i've actually got to set up each
scene render them out and once i've done
that i'm excited to show jordan because
he had to move on to busting an eyeball
and that's great but he's going to love
this
[Music]
i'm very i'm very tired today i'm very
tired but you know what the video's done
this ended up being more work than i
expected but hey that's the theme of
this channel
i gotta say i honestly feel pretty
guilty ren shouldered so much of this
and i have not seen the final product
and i'm incredibly excited i'll talk
about what happened with this process
once we've watched it but for now i'm
gonna hit play
[Music]
wait
[Music]
um
[Music]
that's correct and that's it that's
great that's awesome nice work man that
was a lot of shots that's like 12 that
was 12 shots that was 12 volts
and the entire thing was filmed on my
phone so i ended up doing a little bit
more like manual tweaking of the
animation than i expected to need to do
the deep motion animation ended up
working very well to get something but
it's not exactly like high fidelity you
know it's not going to be as good as a
motion capture suit or hand animating
something but it is so much faster
and then of course i kept refining the
actual glass texture so that ended up
being a bit of a challenge
so one piece of inspiration i took from
the original movie was the fact that
they have a shot in there that was
entirely rendered out of the computer
even though they're using the play
photography they didn't like have to
like recombine it with track mats with
the footage like they did for the other
shots they're just like well it's gonna
be out of focus let's just render it out
and that's the final image
and we're looking at another one right
here this is entirely cg
and i love i remember i saw you working
on this one in particular it's awesome
because
you're able to dial in the depth of
field here in a way that we couldn't do
in camera because all the textures that
we see are projection from a camera onto
the planes in your cgc correct and
what's cool is you're actually getting
the light playing through the glass and
casting red into the shadow and that's
what i was hoping for but i wasn't sure
if it was going to work out and it did i
was so happy i mean it's not clear it's
very subtle you can see that there's
like some red glow you can clearly
subtly see that there's some red glow
the fact that two of us were able to
make this in a week
is
the fact that this is possible at all
yeah is incredible to me there was no
precedent for any of that stuff that
they were doing for the original movie
like the ideas they had were the first
time these ideas were had it's it's hard
to even wrap your mind around that
because i i'm of the mindset that if i
don't have
a help page online or a youtube tutorial
that answers my problems i just assume
it's impossible and that was like their
calling card they're like well no we'll
just make it we'll make it from scratch
there's a special type of person that
can do that and to have like a small
little house full of these guys that
would go on to do such great things and
like this was the birth like at the top
of all the characters we know and love
throughout history there is the stained
glass man we gotta dive in we gotta take
a look we gotta unlock the the secrets
of all these amazing techniques that
were developed just for this
and put our own little spin on it i feel
like we excavated the shoes
from these ancient artists and put them
on our feet and walked along the same
path somehow but like we were able to
put insoles in the excavated shoes this
this is modern shoelaces this is my top
10 favorite metaphors
i really enjoy doing these sort of like
historical deep dives because i take for
granted this sort of access to
technology and
just the general vastness of knowledge
that we have today i'd love to do it
more oh same exactly there are so many
movies out there that i do not know
enough about
leave a comment down below what should
we dive into next
i personally was
very satisfied to see you dancing for
this video and to get that out there and
if you want to actually know more about
that whole sort of dancing my my dancing
origin story
the video is on quarterdigital.com
there's a two week free trial just yeah
gekko do it come on